[Musique]
napoléon bonaparte génie militaire géant
politique grands gestionnaires
il est peut être même le plus grands
chefs militaires de tous les temps
[Musique]
c'était un officier d'artillerie au
départ c'est à dire un homme qui
calculent qu'ils travaillent là-bas
liste et qui travaillent les
emplacements tous ces stratégies de
guerre ont été écrites minutes et
c'était vraiment quelqu'un de très
rationnel napoléon s'est servi du
nationalisme naissant de la france
révolutionnaire pour bâtir le plus grand
empire d'europe depuis les romains
comparé aux héros de l'antiquité qui
l'admirait entre tous alexandre le grand
napoléon ne descendait de personnes il a
su créer sa propre légende
son énergie hors du commun son
intelligence supérieure et son esprit
rebelle lui permirent de conduire sa
nation d'adoption vers une gloire sans
précédent il pense toujours et encore
pouvoir bouleverser le monde
la preuve en est que le talent air à
vienne la monnaie va prendre une valeur
considérable annonce de la mort de
napoléon c'est à dire que à l'agonie il
faisait encore trembler l'humanité une
fois sa puissance établie il se
construisit un personnage sur le modèle
de césar
l'homme d'état et général romain et à
cause de cela il fut considéré comme un
libérateur et en tirant un héros et un
criminel
son désir de puissance et sa
détermination sans faille le meneur au
triomphe puis à la défaite
[Musique]
il ne faut jamais oublier que bonaparte
sur les papiers officiels signés
napoléon par la grâce de dieu et la
volonté des français donc qu'ils
manifestaient à la fois qu'il était
l'héritier des rois de france
comme il était l'héritier également de
la révolution française et de la
démocratie
napoléon devint une légende de son
vivant et reste très présent dans la
conscience collective des français
encore aujourd'hui et c'est bien aussi
son génie les historiens ont beaucoup de
mal à faire la différence entre le mythe
et l'homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voyant bonaparte est un petit bonhomme
qui n'est ajaccio donc rue de la
mauvaise herbe tout de même ça ne
s'invente pas et il est bichonné par sa
maman parce que sa maman elle adore il
est né le jour du 15 ou en plus le futur
empereur des français est le second des
huit enfants de carlo maria buonaparte
et et de maria letizia ramolino pour la
population de cette petite île de la
méditerranée combattre et depuis des
siècles un mode de vie pour garder
l'indépendance nationale sous la
domination italienne
le charismatique pasquale paoli à
unifier les clans qui se livrer des
batailles incessantes
la corse a été acheté par le roi louis
15 à la république de gênes en 1768
napoléon est né en 69
les français débarque alors pour occuper
lille et des rebelles sont rapidement
écrasé à holly s'échappe de justesse et
trouve refuge en angleterre
carlo bonaparte et premier lieutenant de
paoli décide de ne pas le suivre il
préfère rester sur l'île et pactiser
avec les occupants français
son fils napoleone né trois mois plus
tard celui-ci gardera un souvenir
idyllique de ses premières années à
ajaccio ces paroles descend d'une
famille patricienne italienne il jouit
encore d'un statut honorable mais ne
sont pas bien riche et doivent lutter en
permanence pour garder une influence au
sein de toutes les familles nobles qui
habite lille
l'occupation militaire et pacifique et
même bénéfique pour certains mais la
majorité des corses attend le retour de
leur chef parti en exil
napoléon grandi dans une atmosphère
politique
il juge d'abord sévèrement son père pour
son infidélité à la cause de la liberté
mais plus tard il dira à son frère
qu'être du côté des gagnants est pour
lui plus important que n'importe quel
idéal
grâce à ses liens avec le gouverneur
français la famille bonaparte fait
désormais partie de la noblesse
française
cela permet à carlo devenu charles
d'envoyer ses enfants étudier en france
aux frais du roi à 9 ans napoléon
intègre l'école militaire de brienne qui
prépare les enfants de la noblesse
pauvres à une carrière militaire
eh bien il est utile étudie abondamment
surtout les mathématiques le français la
littérature l'orthographe ce sera
toujours le point faible de napoléon
quand on lit les courriers de napoléon
il a une écriture de cochon il commet
trois fautes par ligne mais en revanche
il l'est déjà on sent déjà le
calculateur le stratège qui n'est en lui
habitué à faire partie des hautes
sphères de la société corse
ils se retrouvent citoyens de seconde
classe un étranger aux noms bizarres et
à l'accent prononcé
des seven année on connaît la légende
qui a couru sous la troisième république
autour du jeune bonaparte qui à l'école
de brienne menait ses compagnons pendant
des batailles de boules de neige dans la
cour de l'école militaire
voilà si vous voulez d'apollon est dès
l'origine un militaire il est tout d'un
bloc
[Musique]
en 1784 napoléon réussi les examens qui
lui permettent d'entrer à la
prestigieuse école militaire à paris en
raison de ses aptitudes pour les
mathématiques et la géographie
il est sélectionné dans l'artillerie
napoléon se fait remarquer par son
intelligence et sa détermination
mais il a du mal à s'intégrer bien que
ce soit louis saez qui règle les frais
de son éducation
il exprime ouvertement son mépris pour
les français qui représentent pour lui
l'oppresseur le tyran qui a privé son
pays de la liberté et enchaîner ses
compatriotes
[Musique]
napoléon devient un lecteur acharné ce
qu'il demeurera toute sa vie les
biographies d'anciens chefs militaires
le passionne ainsi que la philosophie et
plus particulièrement les théories de
rousseau sur le droit social
mais quand son père meurt subitement le
jeune napoléon se sont dans l'obligation
de subvenir aux besoins de sa famille il
accomplit en un an un programme de 2
reçoit son affectation de second
lieutenant d'artillerie de l'armée
royale et rejoint son régiment à valence
il a alors 16 ans
on
[Musique]
napoléon serre pendant une année puis
demande un congé de six mois pour aider
sa famille à résoudre ses difficultés
financières
pendant ce temps la monarchie française
s'effondre des décennies de guerre et
des privilèges qui permettent à la
noblesse et au clergé de ne pas payer
d'impôts ont mené l'état la faillite
[Musique]
l'espoir renaît quand le roi louis saez
convoque les états généraux pour trouver
une solution au désastre financier mais
c'est l'impasse politique et la
population se révolte
la prise de la bastille le 14 juillet
1789 marque le début de la révolution
française et la fin d'un régime
archaïque de pression l'assemblée
nationale qui vient d'être institué
aboli les droits féodaux les privilèges
de l'aristocratie provoquant ainsi la
chute de la monarchie
[Musique]
napoléon voit uniquement dans ce coup
d'état ce qui peut favoriser
l'indépendance de la corse après la
déclaration des droits de l'homme la
corse devient un département français
dotée d'un conseil général
[Applaudissements]
faut dire qu'il est quand même du bon
côté de la barricade
il est un gentilhomme mais il assiste
quand même à la révolution avec l'idée
que les rois les rois faible et bien
advienne que pourra 2 il croit que s'il
y a république eh bien il y aura
tellement de désordre qu'il faudra
peut-être faire appel un dictateur et
sans doute des 89 pense-t-il déjà qu'il
pourrait être ce dictateur qui remettra
de l'ordre dans la république
napoléon c'est que paoli n'a jamais eu
l'intention d'ouvrir les portes de son
cercle intime office bonaparte qu'ils
jugent trop ambitieux
en 1792 la france connaît encore de
graves troubles politiques et se
retrouve en conflit avec l'europe en
proie à la ferveur révolutionnaire la
france entre en guerre contre l'autriche
voulons plus se contenter de regarder la
france
emprisonner ses souverains l'autriche et
la prusse sont vite rejointe par la
grande bretagne et d'autres pays pour
former la première coalition contre la
france
la guerre mène à la montée de l'ale
radicale du gouvernement à l'abolition
de la monarchie et à la formation de la
république française la corse qui sort
juste de sa dépendance vis à vis de deux
gènes n'est pas question de lui donner
son indépendance et à ce moment là
paoli lui va se rapprocher de
l'angleterre tandis que les bonaparte se
rapprocheront de la france et le divorce
va aller en s'accroissant ça va devenir
violent virulent la maison des bonaparte
est complètement saccagée ajaccio
[Musique]
les bonaparte sont considérés comme des
traîtres et quitte lille le 10 juin 1793
la famille s'embarque pour la france
afin d'assurer sa sécurité
le rêve de napoléon qui voulait libérer
sa patrie de ses oppresseurs et
restaurer l'honneur de sa famille semble
prendre fin il ne sait pas que sa
véritable mission est sur le point de
commencer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'exécution du roi louis saez en 1793
inaugure le règne de la terreur c'est
une campagne brève mais sanglante menée
par robespierre pour purger la nation de
tous ceux qui seraient susceptibles de
travailler contre les intérêts de la
république ce régicide tétanise les
têtes couronnées d'europe elles
s'allient pour envahir la france
écraser la révolution et restaurer la
lignée des bourbons le jeune
gouvernement français répondent en
instaurant la levée en masse première
conscription à l'échelle nationale du
monde moderne
cette action associé au courant anti
religieux liés à la révolution fait
naître une contre-révolution dans
certaines parties du pays
c'est une période extrêmement dur il
faut pas oublier non plus qu'en vendée
on envoie des armées révolutionnaires ce
sont des sans culottes parisien pour la
plupart coiffés de bonnets phrygiens et
qui se promène de village en village
avec des guillotines on sait qu'en six
mois eut trois cent mille morts en
vendée génocide
on peut bien exprimé le terme alors il
s'agissait de créer la république
d'instituer définitivement dans l'esprit
de robespierre qui remet le chef de
cette période d'instituer définitivement
la république le sud de la france est en
état de guerre civile
les toulonnais vont si loin qu'il invite
les britanniques dans leur propre corps
et forces françaises se précipitent vers
le sud pour écraser la résistance et
reprendre toulon
ami et compatriote christophe salil
shetty le représentant du gouvernement
en mission est en mesure d'obtenir la
nomination de napoléon bonaparte à la
tête de l'artillerie de toulon celui ci
saute sur l'occasion pour montrer ses
talents stratégiques
la stratégie militaire de napoléon se
révèle aussi tôt à toulon en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui a le coup d'oeil
il a immédiatement le coup d'oeil il est
capable de se transformer des plans sur
le champ de bataille
il dresse un brillant plan d' attaque
napoléon a tout de suite vu le point
faible il a vu que c'était au petit
vibre altar c'est-à-dire un fort sur les
hauteurs de toulon qu'il fallait frapper
parce que là en prenant l'artillerie
aussitôt on pouvait arroser les anglais
qui étaient en contrebas les français
tournent les canons vers le port et se
met à bombarder la flotte ennemie
les britanniques n'ont d'autre choix que
de se retirer en ont avec eux les
royalistes français qui ont pu grimper à
bord d'un navire
le général du theil écrite au ministre
de la guerre
je n'ai pas de mots pour vous décrire la
valeur de napoléon il est à vous afin
que vous vous en servier pour la gloire
de la république
bonaparte voit une brillante carrière
s'ouvrir devant lui ayant attiré
l'attention d'hommes puissants comme
robespierre
il est promu à 24 ans général de brigade
[Musique]
mais en juillet 1794 robespierre et
renverser la réaction thermidorienne est
une action des modérés pour reprendre le
contrôle
ses amitiés avec les jacobins valtat
bonaparte d'être arrêté et emprisonné
quelques temps à nice
[Musique]
grâce à ses partisans qui ont survécu au
dernier jour de la terreur
il est finalement libéré et transférée à
paris
[Musique]
quand il arrive le gouvernement met en
place une nouvelle forme de république
on va mettre en place le directoire qui
est un gouvernement de cinq
personnalités
parce qu'on avait très très peur
évidemment du gouvernement d'une seule
personne ce qui avait été le cas avec
robespierre pendant la terreur
donc on va mettre cinq directeurs à la
tête de l'état +2 conseil le conseil des
anciens et le conseil des des 500 qui
sont de simples députés qui vont
instituts et les lois le directoire qui
exclut la participation des royalistes
provoque bientôt une insurrection le 5
octobre 1795 ou 13 vendémiaire en quatre
sous le commandement de paul mara ce
personnage clé du directoire bonaparte
dirige les opérations de défense des
tuileries et remporte la victoire
décisive sur les insurgés devant
l'église saint roch la défaite des
rebelles vaut à bonaparte la protection
du nouveau directoire
il est surnommé le général vendémiaire
il devient commandant en chef de l'armée
de l'intérieur après l'échec de la
campagne de 1795 le directoire prévoit
une offensive sur trois fronts pour
faire sortir l'autriche de la guerre les
manoeuvres en allemagne constitue l'
offensive principale avec une arme et
frappant à partir du sud-est des
pays-bas et une autre poussant à partir
du sud ouest
un troisième corps commandant en chef
doit conduire l'armée d'italie a chassé
les autrichiens du piémont et de la
lombardie dans le nord de l'italie
la nouvelle de la nomination de napoléon
bonaparte à la tête de l'armée d'italie
provoque un choc
l'ancien officier d'artillerie de 26 ans
n'a jamais fait manoeuvrer un régiment
et encore moins une armée entière
bonaparte fait désormais partie de la
société parisienne avenue montaigne à
paris dans une maison qui s'appelle la
chaumière où aller généralement barras
et tous les membres du gouvernement
eh bien il va rencontrer tout un tas de
jolies femmes qui venaient là
parfaitement j'allais dire parfaitement
des nues dénudées pas tout à fait mais
dans des tenues tout à fait affriolantes
des robes transparentes enfin c'était un
véritable lupanar et c'est là qu'il va
tomber sous le charme de la petite
joséphine de beauharnais
c'est une veuve raffiné et sûre d'elle
qui a une inclination pour les hommes de
pouvoir
son mari est mort durant la terreur est
elle-même a échappé de peu à la
guillotine
le 6 mars 1796 deux jours avant son
départ pour l'italie il se marie avec
une joséphine peu enthousiaste il va
bientôt pouvoir se vanter d'avoir
conquis le monde
mais le coeur de joséphine lui échappera
jamais
[Musique]
l'armée d'italie est d'une importance
mineure les subventions qui lui sont
alloués sont bien maigres et l'on attend
pas grand chose d'elle la mission de
bonaparte et d'envahir les plaines du
nord de l'italie alors gouvernée par l'
empire d'autriche
il part en italie pourquoi et bien parce
que il faut protéger les frontières de
la france
et il faut aussi aller défendre les
italiens que les autrichiens menacent
régulièrement
ça fait partie de ce que la république
veut apporter à l'europe
quand bonne part tu arrives à nice pour
le commandement de son armée il la
découvre dans un état lamentable
les généraux de bonaparte dont beaucoup
feront une longue carrière à ses côtés
sont d'abord sceptique à l'arrivée du
jeune artilleur corse
il faut qu'il remporte rapidement une
série de victoires avant de partir
envahir l'italie bonaparte n'a guère que
son talent pour inspirer ses troupes
soldats faisaient tenue mal nourris le
gouvernement vaudois beaucoup il ne peut
rien vous donner
je veux vous conduire dans les plus
fertiles plein du monde de riches
provinces de grandes villes seront en
votre pouvoir vous y trouverez honneur
gloire et richesse
moins de six mois plus tard toute
l'europe est sous le choc devant les
victoires qui l'a remporté
[Musique]
bonaparte et son armée contourne les
alpes et arrive dans le piémont le 9
avril avec ses généraux masséna augereau
serrurier et berthier ils mènent des
opérations une vitesse extraordinaire
maintenant les forces austro sarde du
général jean-pierre de beaulieu à quatre
reprises masséna c'est un un personnage
assez curieux de tout l'est la galaxie
des des généraux et maréchaux d'empiré
il semble même qu'il ait été
contrebandiers dans sa jeunesse et s'est
particulièrement bien comportée pendant
la guerre d'italie et c'est celui que
bonaparte avait appelé l'enfant chéri de
la victoire vaut la part reçoit le 13
avril les drapeaux austro sarde reprises
à millésime au après la bataille de
monter noté il prend la ville de deggo
le 14 est bas les pieds monte à mondovi
le 21 en regardant les alpes enneigées
il avait déclaré hannibal a été obligé
de l'escaladé n'avons fait que les
contourner
bonnes parts construit une stratégie
souple et rapide et à une approche
tactique très moderne avec des armes et
qui sont encore en formation originale
il conduit ses hommes entre deux corps
d'armée et demi les force à se séparer
puis attaque
eva tunnel après l'autre il va
perfectionner cette tactique tout au
long de sa carrière laissant derrière
lui l'armé du piémont l'intrépide
bonaparte et ses généraux avance vers le
nord sur alba et qu'elle as com ce n'est
qu'alors qu'il est enfin en mesure de
fournir le ravitaillement et les
équipements nécessaires pour
réapprovisionner son arme et aurait été
lé l'armée de bonaparte est une armée
qui surprend tous les ennemis qui
surprend l'armée autrichienne qui est
froide guindé son armée à lui c'est
quasiment une âme énorme et de brigands
c'est à dire qu'on ne marque pas de
temps de pause quand on va pas prendre
leur obésité etc
on avance on galope on dit on de telle
sorte que les autres les ennemis seront
véritablement désemparé sans défense est
terrifié par les rumeurs de pillages et
de viols qui précède la proche de
l'armée française le roi de sardaigne
réclame un armistice que bonaparte
accepte maintenant que le piémont a
rompu avec ses alliés autrichien le
général beaulieu retourne protéger milan
napoléon reconnaît les exploits
héroïques de ces hommes et s'adresse
ainsi à la nation italienne peuple
d'italie l'armée française vient rompre
vos chaînes la nation française est
l'amie de toutes les nations venez en
confiance au devant d'elle vos
propriétés votre religion et vos
coutumes seront respectés nous nous
montrerons des ennemis généreux nous
n'en avons qu'après les tyrans qui vous
sont asservis
[Musique]
en deux semaines bonaparte mène une
brillante campagne brise l'armée
piémontaise et gagne le respect de ses
hommes
l'armistice avec le piémont lui garantit
le passage à travers les montagnes vers
la lombardie
il a maintenant des vues sur milan
capitale de la lombardie pour cela il
reçoit de nouveaux renforts pourtant son
armée à 40 mille hommes il peut
poursuivre l'armée autrichienne en
pleine retraite
bonaparte couple générale beaulieu fin
de traverser le pot à valence et on voit
le gros de ses forces à 100 kilomètres
en aval pour lui faire passer le fleuve
à pied senza ma bataille décisive se
déroule le 10 mai dans la ville de
l'audi à quelques kilomètres de bach
quand les français approches du pont de
l'audi le commandement autrichien a déjà
reculé laissant qu'une division de dix
mille hommes pour défendre le pont
rapidement celle ci bat en retraite
la route vers milan est ouverte
c'est une victoire mineurs mais elle
offre à napoléon le contrôle de la
lombardie le théâtre de guerre italien
est considéré jusqu'à présent comme
secondaire semble devenir l'élément
charnière de cette guerre
napoléon dira plus tard ce soir là pour
la première fois je ne me suis pas
considérer simplement comme en général
mais comme un homme appelé à décider du
sort des peuples
une part du génie de napoléon est liée à
sa capacité à exploiter ses victoires en
même temps qu'il se battait il était
également conscient qu'il lui fallait
cultiver son image à travers les
rapports et les dépêches qu'il écrivait
sur le terrain est envoyé à paris il va
multiplier les bulletins qui deviendront
les bulletins de la grande armée grâce
auquel il va déjà écrire effectivement
sa légende en dehors des victoires elle
même exagéré les pertes de l'ennemi est
une technique dont il s'est servi de
façon très efficace en cas de
retournement de situation il omettait
simplement certains détails et insisté
sur l'héroïsme de ces hommes après
l'audi napoléon marche sur milan et voit
la vie lui ouvrir ses portes
la plupart des officiers et des soldats
qui passent sous les trois arches de la
porta romana sont vêtus de haillons mais
ils n'en sont pas moins accueilli en
libérateur mais la confiance qui régnait
au sein de la population italienne est
mise à mal
quand bonaparte lhc sommes affamés
victorieux et en manque de femmes sur
les citoyens sans méfiance
bonaparte créé plusieurs républiques
pour stabiliser la région à long terme
toutes les révoltes qui éclate après son
départ comme à milan et pavie son
réprimer avec brutalité les français
continuent à poursuivre l'armée
autrichienne qui se retirent
ils prennent les villes qui se trouvent
sur leur chemin et assiègent finalement
la dernière grande cité de lombardie
mentaux
cette forteresse très bien protégés et
le quartier général des forces
autrichienne mais le siège n'est pas
terminée quand bonaparte reçoit l'ordre
d'avancer vers le centre et le sud de
l'italie
[Musique]
d'abord à milan puis dans les duché de
parme et de modène bonaparte impose une
clause de contribution de guerre en
argent et oeuvres d'art de grande valeur
en préalable à toute négociation d'un
armistice à la tête du commandement de
l'armée d'italie
eh bien il fait merveille comme chef de
guerre l'une après l'autre jeune parme
modène la toscane et rome tombe sous ses
offensives
des trains ramène le butin de guerre
l'or l'argent les bijoux et les oeuvres
d'art à travers les alpes avant
d'arriver à paris
que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
coût
le pape pie xi se demande un armistice
et d'autres trésors tombent dans les
caisses françaises
du matériel et des canons sont envoyés à
mantoue pour soutenir le siège fin juin
beaulieu est remplacé par le général
autrichien 20h25 homme arrive en
provenance du rhin vont êre lance la
première de ses quatre tentatives en
l'espace de six mois pour délivrer
mantoue et reprendre le contrôle du nord
de l'italie
vérone tombe aux mains autrichienne en
juillet pour éviter un effondrement
complet des positions françaises trop
étendue bonaparte doit absolument
arrêter les bataillons de volontaires
ils déplacent rapidement ses troupes et
les concentre à des endroits critiques
quelques jours de campagne acharnée
napoléon balles et les forces hausse
trop tarder à lonato attaque et prend
castiglione et enfin reprend vérone
forçant vont êre épuisé et défait à
battre en retraite
les français sont encore vainqueur à
rovereto le 4 septembre et à bassano le
8 en novembre
épaulés par des renforts venus du nord
les autrichiens lance d'une nouvelle
offensive pour mettre fin au siège de
manteaux à cannes 0 il inflige aux
français un des rares vers tactiques
qu'ils vont essuyer et force bonaparte à
se retirer à vérone
[Musique]
c'est un homme qui croit en son étoile
et qui fait tout pour aller dans le sens
c'est un homme qui ne se posent pas de
questions qui n'a pas de cas de
conscience
donc c'est un homme qui se laisse aller
à ses instants d'une certaine façon
bonaparte ne dispose plus que de 13
mille hommes il lui a fallu battre en
retraite et abandonner le blocus qu'il
exerçait au tour de mantoue mais les
autrichiens ne tirent aucun avantage de
leur victoire
ceux qui décident le général français à
repartir à l'attaqué
bonaparte sens que c'est le moment de
porter le coup décisif
ces hommes sont prêts à mourir pour lui
et tombe sur l'armée ennemie à l'est de
vérone
c'est là qu'a lieu la fameuse bataille
d'arcole
[Musique]
le premier jour les forces françaises et
autrichiennes s'affrontent séparées par
la rivière album est un pont de bois
tous ceux qui du côté français tentent
de traverser le pont tombe sous le feu
des canons posté sur la rive opposée
[Musique]
en fait c'est le général augereau qui
voulant en finir se précipitent parmi
les lignes de soldats effrayer saisie
d'un drapeau et avant sur l'ennemi
mais la réplique est si forte qu'il est
obligé de revenir à son point de départ
voyant cela bonaparte avance prend le
drapeau et répète ce geste héroïque
quand les autrichiens ouvrent le feu il
est entraîné à l'écart du champ de
bataille par ses ordres il a la chance
de pouvoir s'échapper sans être blessés
alors que plusieurs de ceux qui
l'accompagnent sont touchés ou tués
[Musique]
ne parvenons pas à traverser à arcole
les français doivent attendre deux jours
de plus avant de reprendre l'initiative
et de remporter la victoire
napoléon inflige une défaite décisive
aux autrichiens lors de la bataille de
rivoli
[Musique]
et le 2 février 1797 ceux ci se voient
obligés de capituler un manteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonaparte et à quelques kilomètres de
vienne quand l'autriche accepte un
traité préliminaire il outrepassé ses
pouvoirs en négociant la paix de leoben
et le directoire dont l'autorité est
affaibli et si talent empêché le
gouvernement est si faible qu'il donne
là et qu'il laisse le porte ouverte à
tous les excès alors on a toujours les à
commun le plus extrémiste qui s'agitent
sur la gauche du gouvernement doit même
qu'à droite on a un retour également des
royalistes
il passe les mois suivants à établir des
républiques en italie c'est plus une
stratégie militaire qu'un processus
idéologique mais ce processus va faire
de lui l'un des fondateurs de l'unité
italienne
le traité de campo forme you avec
l'autriche conclu victorieusement la
campagne d'italie et marc l'éclatement
de la première coalition la pole et on a
beaucoup appris en italie à présent une
croix fermement son destin et déclarera
nous avons noyer la honte de la
révolution dans les flots de la gloire
[Musique]
à son retour le général bonaparte reçoit
un accueil triomphal
un banquet est organisée en son honneur
dans la grande galerie du louvre
alors à son retour d'italie
le directoire l'accueil naturellement en
le remerciant de ses exploits mais en se
méfiant de lui aussi parce que on se dit
ce petit général a peut-être beaucoup
d'ambition et on ne sait pas ce qui ce
qui lui passe par la tête
donc méfions nous de lui il est placé un
peu sous surveillance le directoire
craignant à juste titre que bonaparte
utilise l'armé et le soutien populaire
pour s'emparer du pouvoir
ça arrange pour l'envoyer de nouveau en
mission il est nommé général en chef de
l'armée d'angleterre il reçoit l'ordre
d'attaquer les îles britanniques
l'angleterre est le principal ennemi de
la france est elle qui tire le commerce
mondial et qui tient également le crédit
avec lequel elle prête de l'argent à
tous les états d'europe
ce à quoi veut s'opposer la france alors
c'est la france royal depuis louis xiv
aussi bien que la france de napoléon il
n'y a pas eu la de révolution du tout
dans la politique française
c'est une vieille tradition donc de
lutter contre l'angleterre
napoléon et mais une autre proposition
il s'agit d'affaiblir l'angleterre en
s'emparant de l'egypte
le contrôle de l'égypte permettrait de
réduire la distance qui sépare la france
des indes et de leurs richesses alors
sous contrôle britannique
les anglais suivent toujours le trajet
le plus long en passant par l'afrique du
sud en ayant un pied en egypte
les français pourraient raccourcir la
route des indes avec l'aide de
talleyrand alors ministre des affaires
étrangères bonaparte persuade le
directoire de choisir un autre théâtre
d'opérations et de quitter la manche
pour aller vers l'orient on va essayer
de se prendre sans prendre aux anglais
mais en egypte qu'ils occupent
et puis on va essayer par la même
occasion de libérer le blocus sur la
méditerranée si bien que bonaparte est
nommé à la tête de cette arme et
l'egypte et il s'en va là bas avec tes
des milliers et des milliers d'hommes
mais aussi la l'intelligence d'emmener
avec lui des savants des mathématiciens
des dessinateurs qui vont faire des
relevés des croquis qui vont étudier un
petit peu la civilisation égyptienne
la traversée de la méditerranée commence
le 19 mai 1798 bonaparte emmène avec lui
trente quatre mille fantassins et 16
milles marins
à cela s'ajoute le soutien de civils au
nombre de 1000 et une commission de 167
membres chargés d'effectuer des
recherches scientifique et archéologique
la flotte comprenant près de 400 bateaux
navires de guerre frégate et vaisseaux
marchands couvre une surface de 3 à 5
kilomètres carrés sur la mer l'amiral
anglais horatio nelson ne tarde pas à
donner l'ordre de localiser et de
détruire la flotte française bonaparte
fait une première escale dans une île
d'importance stratégique
malte comme il l'a déjà fait en italie
il établit un gouvernement provisoire
confisqué les trésors et les stocks
d'armes herbach pour l'étape suivante
alexandrie en egypte
la côte africaine est en vue treize
jours plus tard le 1er juillet
craignant de voir surgir à l'horizon à
tout moment la flotte de nelson voilà
partent se hâtent d'accoster dans la
baie d'aboukir malgré le mauvais temps
ces sommes sont épuisés et manque
désespérément tôt mais le général de
leur laisse aucun répit au matin il
prend le contrôle d'alexandrie en
expliquant aux turcs que la france et
leurs alliés et qu'elle vient libérer
l'egypte de l'oppression des mamelouks
bien que l'egypte fasse partie de
l'empiré ottoman ce qui en fait une
province turque
elle est gouvernée par les mamelouks une
caste guerrière d'anciens esclaves qui
ont renversé les sultans égyptiens au
12e siècle
la déclaration d'alliance avec la
turquie de bonaparte descamps partie
frais
[Musique]
talleyrand accepte de rendre visite aux
sultans ottomans pour l'informer de ce
projet mais ce que bonaparte ignore
c'est que talleyrand ne fera pas ce
voyage
il pense donc n'avoir affaire qu'à un
seul ennemi les mamelouks et se retrouve
bientôt à devoir combattre aussi les
turcs
[Musique]
bonaparte avant sur le caire mais il est
évident que ses troupes ne sont pas
préparés à affronter le désert
beaucoup d'hommes meurent de soif à
peine sorti d'alexandrie
[Musique]
il remporte la victoire et oblige
l'armée mamelouks à battre en retraite
puis poursuivent leur marche et s'empare
du caire mais à partir de là ma campagne
tourne au désastre
tout ce qui est mathématique tout ce qui
tourne autour de la guerre pour napoléon
ça ne me pose aucun problème
il n'y a qu'une qu'un domaine dans
lequel il était très ignorants en
matière militaire c'était la marine et
malheureusement c'est peut-être sur la
marine qu'il aurait dû axer ses efforts
pour vaincre l'angleterre
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard la flotte de
nelson arrive dans la baie d'aboukir où
les navires français sont encore à
l'encré et lancent une attaque surprise
l'amiral français bruce a disposé ces
navires de guerre sur une ligne de 2 km
de l'an 500 canons sont dirigés vers le
large
mais ils sont éloignés de la terre et
plusieurs navires de nelson en profite
pour prendre position sur la côte
la bataille du nil fait rage sans
interruption pendant 24 heures les
normes vaisseau orient fierté de la
marine françaises explosent les
britanniques remportent une victoire
décisive
ils sont capturés ou détruit 11 des
navires de la flotte française
nelson installe un blocus dans la baie
avant de partir
les français sont bloqués ils ne peuvent
plus rentrer chez eux
en octobre bonaparte réprime avec succès
une révolte de la population du caire
sur son ordre
les arabes sont repoussés dans le désert
et l'artillerie investi la mosquée de la
ville où s'étaient retranchés des
insurgés les relations d'amitié avec l'
empire ottoman qui durait depuis
longtemps prenne fin la politique
expansionniste de napoléon bonaparte
force la turquie a déclaré la guerre à
la france quand le général apprend que
l'armée turque s'apprête à envahir
l'egypte avec le soutien de la russie et
de l'angleterre
il décide de la détourner vers la syrie
[Musique]
on l'a envoyé dans une sorte de guêpier
parce qu'il a dû aller guerroyer
jusqu'en syrie il a dû ses troupes ont
été décimés par la peste est un moment
très dur
bonaparte sécurisé d'abord le port de
jaffa en massacrant sa population avant
de quitter la ville il donne l'ordre de
tuer et de passer à la baïonnette 2000 à
3000 prisonniers turc
cette série de victoires s'achève à
saint jean d'âcre la forteresse célèbre
pour avoir été conquise pendant les
croisades par richard coeur de lion
serait tombé sans difficulté s'il
n'avait été défendue avec vaillance par
le capitaine britannique williams pis la
pole et on envoie ses hommes à l'assaut
à leurs attaques renouvelées courte à
l'échec
il perd beaucoup d'hommes au cours de
ces offensives et à cause de la peste au
bout de deux mois infructueux
les français se retire d'égypte
quand il arrive au caire bonaparte a
perdu un tiers de son armée son avenir
politique est en jeu il fait défiler ses
hommes drapeaux en tête en prétendant
être le vainqueur
quand les turcs accoste dans la baie
d'aboukir en juillet en appart les
affronte avec dix mille hommes et
renvoie une grande partie de ses ennemis
à la mer la bataille d'aboukir est une
victoire capitale pour la france
[Musique]
bonaparte apprend que la france est de
nouveau en guerre
les russes n'ont pas accepté la prise de
malte les autrichiens n'ont jamais signé
le traité de paix et reprennent le
contrôle de l'allemagne et de l'italie
le gouvernement français connaît une
nouvelle crise politique et financière
à ce moment bonaparte comprend que son
projet d'affronter les britanniques en
inde est un rêve impossible
[Musique]
il se sent un petit peu pris de panique
si bien qu' il va déléguer tous les
pouvoirs à kléber en egypte et il va
partir mais véritablement presque comme
un malpropre c'est à dire discrètement
il va traverser la méditerranée
au risque de se faire et prôné par par
la flotte par britannique et il rejoint
la corse et de live rejoint la france
abandonnant un peu quand même son armée
en egypte bonaparte quitte le caire avec
une poignée d'hommes pour la france il
laisse derrière lui le général jean
baptiste kléber et toute une armée
envahi par le désespoir et la nostalgie
de la patrie
celle ci va rester encore deux en egypte
avant de se rendre au britannique ce qui
donne amplement le temps à bonaparte de
se servir de ses exploits de la campagne
d'égypte pour faire avancer sa carrière
on sent qu'il revient avec toutes sortes
d'appétit politique il ne veut plus être
un chef de guerre
c'est pour ça il estime qu'il a été
piégé en partant en egypte et il a
l'impression qui n'est pas fausse
d'ailleurs qu'on l'a éloigné
[Musique]
bonaparte et reçu très fraîchement par
les membres du directoire à l'exception
de barras et de sieyès qui désireux de
s'assurer son soutien courtisent tous
deux le jeune général barras est un
noble d'ancien régime il est vicomte le
vicomte de barras c'est un homme qui a
connu le xviiie siècle facile de cette
noblesse justement du règne de louis
saez
c'est un homme qui aime briller qui aime
être entouré de femmes c'est un homme
extrêmement intelligent mais un peu
dilettante si j'ose dire
barras à des expirations loyalistes et
espère restaurer les bourbons sur le
trône de france est à l'opposé vous avez
vieillesse alors sieyès lui c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est un déclassé sociale on hamm est
mia qui en fait ne crois absolument pas
en dieu c'est le déclasser qui tire les
ficelles dans l'ombre bonaparte possède
à présent un immense pouvoir politique
et militaire
il a également amassé une grande fortune
il possède tous les éléments pour faire
monter le coup d'état du 18 brumaire
le directoire est remplacé par le
consulat le pouvoir exécutif est
maintenant assurée par trois consuls
élus donc d'une part il y a d'abord
bonaparte qui est le premier consul et
qui détient véritablement le pouvoir
ensuite deux autres consul qui seront
cambacérès et le brun 2e et 3e consul
donc qui en fait plutôt un rôle de
représentation bonaparte se fait nommer
premier consul le pouvoir parlementaire
et militaire repose à présent
entièrement entre ses mains pour mettre
un terme au chaos qui règne en france
il veut instaurer un gouvernement
républicain centralisée et autoritaire
lui qui avait consacré la première
partie de sa vie à lutter contre la
tyrannie va finir par ce sacré lui même
empereur
quelle ironie
m
la rapide accession au pouvoir de
napoléon en terre les acquis de la
révolution française
son ambition insatiable va d'abord
devenir son atout majeur puis son plus
grand handicap
il va permettre à la france d'atteindre
une puissance qui n'a encore jamais
connu puis la mettre à genoux quand son
génie et son ego l'entraîneront trop
loin et lui feront perdre le contrôle
des événements
enfin quand son empire s'effondrera
autour de lui il tournera son regard
vers les sommets de la postérité
continuer à vivre au-delà de lui-même
c'est pour lui le symbole ultime de la
grandeur et la raison pour laquelle sa
quête de gloire ne peut avoir de fin